ربه منزل وفي رعايتها تسعه ابناء تحمل
درجه دبلوم ولا تشغل شيئا في المجتمع هكذا
كان حال الهنديه
2005 لتصبح بين ليله وضحاها قطبا سياسيا
واقتصاديا في الهند ثم اغنى سيده هنديه
بثروه تتجاوز 18 مليار دولار فكيف حدث ذلك
عام 1950 ونشات في مدينه تنسوكي الهنديه
قبل ان تتزوج من ارمله شقيقتها في عام
1970 وهو ام جندل فتولت وهي في الخامسه
عشر من عمرها تربيه ابناء شقيقتها وزوجها
الاربعه كما انجبت خمسه ابناء ما جعلها
تركز على نشاطها العائليه وتؤثر دور ربه
المنزل على الحياه العمليه بقي الحال كذلك
حتى عام 2005 حين توفي زوجها بح في تحطم
مروحيه لتجد نفسها وهي في سن الخامسه
والخمسين في مواجهه مع رعايه اسره كبيره
لا تنتهي عند باب منزلها بل تتعدى ذلك لما
تركه من ارث كبير وهي مجموعه جندل
الاقتصاديه قطب صناعه الصلب والطاقه
بالاضافه الى شركات تعمل في مجال التعدين
وتوليد الطاقه والغازات الصناعيه ومنشات
الموانئ وهي امبراطوريه اسسها اومجدال
الذي ولد لمزارع في ولايه هاريا الهنديه
عام
1930 بدات القصه عندما كان ام صبيا مهما
بتكنولوجيا والهندسه كان يزور مشاغل تصليح
السيارات ويتطوع للمساعده حتى صادف انبوبا
فولاذيه كتب عليه صنع في انجلترا ليبدا
التفكير بصناعه مشابهه يكتب عليها صنع في
الهند فاسس وحده تصنيع انابيب متواضعه عام
قام بمفرده بتطوير جميع الالات الخاصه
بالعمل دون الحصول على درجه علميه او خبره
في الهندسه ثم طورها لمصنع اكبر في عام
1964 باستثمار قدره 42,000 روبيه قبل ان
يطلق شركه جلدا لمده في غضون عقود قليله
تحولت المجموعه الى اربعه تكتلات عملاقه
في صناعه الصلب والتعدين والطاقه عمل على
توليتها لابنائه اثناء حياته لم يكتفي امه
القادم من بيئه ريفيه بالتتبع على عرش
الاقتصاديه ليقتحم عالم السياسه حيث اصبح
اول رجل صناعيا في البرلمان الهنديه في
عام
1996 كما كان وزيرا للسلطه في الحكومه
الهنديه لولايه هاريان الشماليه وهي
المكانه التي ورثتها زوجته ايضا فبعد
وفاته نقلت اصوله الشخصيه الى سافيتري
التي بدات مسارا مهنيا سياسيه الى جانب
رئاستها لمجموعه جندل فاصبحت مشرعه في
ولايه هاريانا شمال الهند في عام 2005 و
2009 كما شغلت حقائب وزيره الدوله
للايرادات واداره الكوارث واعاده التاهيل
والاسكان في عام 2006 ووزيره الهيئات
المحليه الحضريه في عام 2013 وفي عهدها
زاد معدل نمو المجموعه 4 مرات وتوسعت
اعمالها كما نامت ثروتها لتبلغ 18 مليارن
ومئتين مليون دولار في عام 2022 وهو ما
جعلها اغنى سيده في الهند ويحدى اكثر عشر
سيدات ثراء في العالم لكن الانتصار الابرز
في مسيرتها انها استطاعت ان تحافظ على
ارثا كبيره عماد والسلطه وبالتاكيد
العائله
[موسيقى]